the jurgen experience
i had a conversation once when i was uh
just starting to get into acting um i
had uh i think
maybe i'd just been cast in the news
radio and i got brought maybe not even
i've been brought in to meet with these
producers because they knew i had a
martial arts background they wanted to
talk about
me doing a martial arts movie and the
interview did not go very well
because because they were talking about
um things in movies like all these
wild scenes and and they were asking me
what i like and i go
well i like things that are realistic i
want i want to see something that i know
would work
like if if a guy you know jumps up and
split kicks two people
and and knocks him across the room like
that doesn't
i don't i go i want to see like
realistic scenarios where
where a person who knows martial arts
can go oh that
that's pretty badass like like chuck
norris give him
all the [ __ ] you want but there's a lot
of chuck norris movies we had like real
realistic
fight scenes yeah like um what was the
the cop movie chuck norris did lone wolf
mcquade no
no that was the one we fought uh david
carradine there was a
is that how he fights yeah he never like
no matter like they they
killed his dog and then he got pissed
that was pushing it too far there was
one movie with it where
chuck norris did oh god it's not the
thin blue line is it
what is it code of silence that's right
that was
a movie where it was a real movie like
it wasn't
it wasn't just like a karate movie it
was like a real
movie it was a good it was like what
critically occurred was probably 1980 as
well like what year was that movie here
he's in a bar next to this speaks to you
jokes he's by a pool table getting ready
to karate fight
85 yeah i was got everything you like it
wasn't
too outrageous it was like he was really
fighting like it made it made
sense like you could see that happening
and maybe that's not the best example
you know who's a good example
as weird as it sounds steven seagal's
early movie
above the law and a lot of people hate
saying that
i [ __ ] loved above the law that
stephen cigar movie when he [ __ ]
people up in a bar
like you believed it yeah i'm like he's
not doing jumping spinning wheel kicks
or anything like that
he's cracking people over the head with
pool cues and breaking their arms
it's like that all that stuff like okay
i buy that
i buy that i would someday like you to
do a um live
like an analysis a sort of director's
cut style analysis of the fight scene at
the end of cannonball run
this is steven seagal walking in dude
this was back when he was lean
i met him and uh i met him in a catfish
joint in oxford mississippi
a catfish plant is there getting fried
catfish really
do you remember when he was a real cop
on a television show
people got mouthy with him in this movie
and it's not a good move bang
starts [ __ ] people up see that look
at that elbow that upward elbow 100
legit 100 real move that you see in muay
thai
all the time that's real that kevin ross
could be doing that right now right
there
bam that's 100 legit knee to the face
all all legit that stuff makes sense
look this guy's gonna swing boom
all this [ __ ] this is real this is this
is steven seagal
at his best these are like legit
believable fight scenes oh now he's
gonna get
but watch this even the way like why is
it steven seagal people talk a lot of
[ __ ] about him but steven seagal was a
legit aikido master like he was one of
the first if not the first american
to teach uh at a dojo in japan he taught
akito
he was a hundred percent legit when i
met him he was wearing some kind of robe
he lost the script somewhere along the
line but back then
during this movie man i [ __ ] loved
that guy and i remember bringing him
up in the meeting and i'm and i'm
bringing this scene up i'm like that's
that's what i want to see i don't want
to see [ __ ] that i know won't work
and they weren't into it and they were
like people don't know that i go but i
know that
and he says yeah but how many people are
you like you were out there you know i
go but that movie's a successful movie
and the guy got upset at me
yeah he just didn't want to hear me
criticizing his perspective on something
that i was an
actual expert in has gq asked you to do
one of those breakdowns
would you what of a karate scene in a
movie well no they like i've done the
breakdown where you watch all the
hunting scenes
oh have you done that yeah yeah it's fun
i'd probably do that without gq
i don't want them in the in the mix you
don't need them in there why would i
want
why would i want anybody else in there
then you have a producer then you have a
big organization behind you
when you can just do it here episodes of
the joe rogan experience are now
free on spotify that's right they're
free
from september 1st to december 1st
they're going to be available everywhere
but after december 1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love